Figaro live bonjour bienvenue il est
l'heure du 49 3 il est attendu depuis
plusieurs jours et dans quelques minutes
Elisabeth borne va annoncer
l'utilisation de cet article de la
Constitution qui permet de faire passer
un texte sans vote le budget 2023 sera
donc adopté grâce au 49 3 c'est plutôt
rare mais c'était semble-t-il
obligatoire cette fois-ci on va tout
vous expliquer on va suivre la prise de
parole de la première ministre dans
l'hémicycle Je vous remonte ces images
mais il est ici pour l'instant en débat
Dyna Cohen on débarque sur cette et bien
sûr ce budget pour l'instant comme si de
rien n'était le principe de l'Assemblée
nationale donc pour l'instant tout le
monde est dans l'hémicycle tout le monde
débat l'air de rien même tout le monde
sait ce qui va se passer mais jusqu'au
bout on poursuit les débats tout le
monde joue le jeu en sachant que c'est
quand même un peu un grand théâtre
puisque la personne a de doute sur ce
qui va se passer personne n'a doute
depuis une semaine sur ce qui va se
passer mais bon on joue le jeu quand
même on débat on adopte des choses on
modifie le texte tout ça pour que pour
que le 49 3 arrive dans quelques minutes
on va suivre la prise de parole donc de
la première année c'est prévu à 17h30
nous verrons s'il y a du retard puis les
réactions des oppositions ensuite Dina
je vous ai même pas présenté journaliste
au service politique du Figaro merci
d'être ici
à Wally Bordas notre autre journaliste
est sur place qui me dit que la tension
monte que l'hémicycle est plein à
craquer comment ça va se passer c'est
assez étonnant elle va alors elle était
au Sénat avant que son gouvernement au
Sénat donc là ça veut dire qu'elle va
arriver
directement depuis le Sénat il va y
avoir une suspension de séance pour que
y a le bon Pivet la présidente
macroniste de l'Assemblée nationale
président de la séance parce que là pour
l'instant c'est le député
Marine Le Pen a qui lève la main et qui
fait signe donc Sébastien Chenu qui est
vice-président du RN mais pour un
événement comme celui-ci c'est la
présidence c'est ça qui va venir et puis
et puis bah ils avaient bornes va
prendre la parole et va expliquer que
quel langage
l'article 49 alinéa 3 pour du coup clore
les débats et
faire adopter le texte sans la case des
bas sans la case vote des députés ni
dessinateur parce que ça met fin à tout
le tout le processus législatif on peut
répéter des dizaines de fois sûrement
vous ici sur ce plateau hier avec
François-Xavier avec terminus mais il
faut réexpliquer à nos internautes
qu'est-ce que très simplement le 49-3
alors c'est ce que les oppositions
appellent un passage en force c'est
pouvoir adopter un texte à l'Assemblée
nationale sans passer par la case vote
des députés là la machine législative
traditionnelle c'est le vote des députés
puis la lecture au Sénat puis ça revient
au députés et on essaye de s'entendre
dans une commission
là on est en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale et ça va s'arrêter
là ça met fin à tout il y aura pas de
scénario il y aura pas de commission
mixte c'est le 49-3 qui met fin au débat
et qui permet de remanier le texte aussi
parce que du coup le gouvernement peut
mettre un peu ce qu'il veut dans le
texte qui va adopter par 49-3 et on peut
pas l'utiliser n'importe quand
[Musique]
avant avant on pouvait utiliser autant
qu'on voulait avant la loi de 2008 si je
comprends pas
mais c'est plus le cas parce que ça a
été très employé sous certains
gouvernements et donc maintenant on peut
l'utiliser une fois sur le texte du
budget donc c'est le temps de fois qu'on
veut sur le même texte on a le budget et
on a et on a aussi le PLFSS qui le
budget sécurité sociale qui va arriver
la semaine prochaine et en dehors de ça
on peut l'utiliser sur un texte
par session donc ça veut dire que la
session extraordinaire de l'été on peut
l'utiliser une fois et la session
ordinaire de l'année on peut l'utiliser
une fois alors là on sait à peu près à
quel moment ce sera théoriquement ce
sera pour la réforme des retraites non
vous avez raison c'est pas exclu non
plus que que le gouvernement n'obtienne
pas le soutien de la républicains sur la
retraite
au mois de février
17h20 nous sommes en direct vous voyez
ici les débats à l'Assemblée nationale
des débats qui portent sur le budget là
c'est la question de l'Europe d'ailleurs
si vous voulez tout savoir mais
théoriquement d'ici 8 minutes Elisabeth
borne devrait débarquer dans l'Assemblée
nationale et annoncer donc que tous ces
débats non servi à rien ou presque et
que et bien ce budget sera adopté sans
vote j'ai envie de vous dire c'est c'est
pas trop tôt parce que c'était une
éluable dans cette situation de de faire
appel aux 49-3 c'est vrai que quand on
voit régulièrement les députés les
parlementaires depuis le début de l'été
il nous parle de ce budget depuis le
début de l'été depuis qu'ils sont élus
et ils nous disent que la grosse
séquence très dure de la rentrée ça va
être le budget et que de toute façon il
y a 99% de probabilité pour que le
budget finissent par 49,3
parce que le budget c'est un marqueur en
fait des oppositions et de la majorité
S c'est ce qui reflète ça fait partie
des textes qui reflètent le plus la
politique d'un gouvernement et
traditionnellement voter pour le budget
c'est quasiment être dans la majorité
c'est dire qu'on est partenaire alliés
de la majorité donc même si on l'a vu
cet été il y a des accords qui sont
possibles dans cette nouvelle assemblée
avec des oppositions quand on leur donne
des gages etc votez un budget c'est trop
c'est c'est vraiment faire un pas dans
la majorité donc quand on est une
opposition on ne peut pas au niveau du
message politique que ça envoie on ne
peut pas voter le budget de la majorité
mais sachant que donc le gouvernement
n'a pas de majorité depuis le mois de
mai juin dernier depuis les élections
législatives évidemment depuis le mois
de juin dernier oui pourquoi on a
négocié pourquoi on a perdu autant de
temps là pourquoi le 49 3 n'a pas été
dégainé dès le début de discussion il y
a eu un doute sur la stratégie à adopter
et ce qu'on l'emploie tout de suite et
ce qu'on l'emploi à la fin des débats
tout ça s'explique par des raisons
politiques parce qu'en fait le calcul
c'est quoi c'est se dire
si on utilise tout de suite le 49-3 si
je me mets dans la peau de ta montre de
l'exécutif ou de la majorité ça veut
dire que on a même pas essayé de
discuter avec une assemblée qui pourtant
est faite de telle manière que les
Français nous envoient un message pour
qu'on essaie de culture du compromis du
dialogue si on emploie tout de suite le
49-3 on dit directement on veut pas de
votre avis on passe en force point or si
on fait durer les débats qu'on montre
qu'on a essayé
mais qu'en fait c'est en face que ça ne
marche pas et que de toute façon les
oppositions de voteront pas là le le
message politique envoyé et un peu
différent puisqu'on montre qu'on a
essayé
dans le message
oui la finalité est connu depuis le
début après avec du coup des nuances
puisque maintenant vu qu'il y a eu les
débats peut-être qu'il y a des
amendements qui ont été adoptés et qui
vont être gardés par le gouvernement je
vous coupe Dina parce que Marine Le Pen
prend la parole dans l'assemblée c'est
une des figures de la politique
française évidemment on va l'écouter
vous qui êtes fascinés par l'Allemagne
mais dites-moi l'Allemagne a obtenu un
rabais me semble-t-il et il ne me semble
pas que l'Allemagne que vous chérissez
tant chouette sortir de l'Union
européenne soit affaiblir l'Union
européenne le Danemark a obtenu un
rabais les Pays-Bas ont obtenu à rabais
la Suède à obtenir un rabais l'Autriche
a obtenu un rabais
il n'y a que la France
il n'y a que la France qui comme je l'ai
dit et comme l'a dit Jean-Philippe
Tanguy pigeon de l'Union européenne ne
cesse d'augmenter année après année sa
contribution nette alors même que vous
réclamez des Français de ce serrer la
ceinture alors même que vous expliquez
que notre budget est à l'euro près alors
même que vous leur imposez la sobriété
c'est ça le sujet essentiel et je vais
vous dire dans le domaine de l'Union
européenne c'est en réalité comme dans
le domaine du budget de la France la
vraie question ça n'est pas le
consentement à cette impôt ou à cette
contribution c'est le consentement à la
dépense les Français ne sont pas
d'accord avec la manière dont vous
dépensez l'argent que ce soit au niveau
national ou que ce soit au niveau
européen
bien je suis assez fasciné par ce qui se
passe parce que on le rappelle bon dans
4 minutes ce sera peut-être pas le cas
mais
Elisabeth borne enfin pas
va venir dans les 10 minutes qui
viennent mais elle doit venir à 17h30
elle va mettre un terme à tous débat là
et on continue à faire ce spectacle là
c'est très étonnant non de toute façon
l'Assemblée nationale
est un endroit c'est une des parties du
cœur du pouvoir mais c'est aussi un
grand théâtre celle-ci le lieu où on
sait que le pouvoir est vu que les
débats sont écoutés surtout depuis cette
nouvelle mandature ou les Français ont
plus d'intérêt pour cette assemblée
puisqu'elle est puisqu'elle a été
particulièrement redessinée et donc oui
on joue le jeu jusqu'au bout et ça et
pour revenir sur ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure non seulement finalement le
l'exécutif a fait le choix de d'avoir
des débats pour montrer que ce qu'ils
essayent d'être dans le dialogue mais
ils se sont fait un petit peu piéger
aussi parce qu'en fait les débats ont
été plutôt de bonne tenue on a eu un
groupe insoumique et qui s'est quand
même relativement bien comporté
par rapport aux chaînes de faire
davantage cet été
on peut expliquer ce qui se passe un
amendement vient d'être voté et ça
continue on va écouter parce que
peut-être que Sébastien Chenu va
expliquer ce qui va se passer dans les
minutes qui le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votre temps 385 exprimé 358 majorité 180
pour 212 contre 146 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté l'article 25
et je suspends la séance pour 10 minutes
ah voilà c'est intéressant j'ai deux
questions suspension de séance pour 10
minutes ça veut dire que d'ici une
dizaine de minutes donc Dina Cohen
Elizabeth borne devrait être dans
l'hémicycle changement de président avec
la présidence officielle finalement
enfin
puisque Sébastien Chenu n'est que
vice-président de l'Assemblée et il l'a
remplace à l'occasion donc sera au
perchoir et donc elle devrait annoncer
le 49-3 on y revient donc dans un
instant on vient de voir là un
amendement a été voté ça veut dire que
tout ce qui a été voté depuis le début
de la semaine c'est oublier ou pas
vraiment alors
théoriquement là le gouvernement va
pouvoir mettre ce qu'il veut dans ce
texte à partir où il active le l'article
49 alinéa 3
après une fois de plus dans le domaine
du message politique il y a aussi et
encore une volonté de de montrer qu'on
écoute quand même les oppositions
d'autant plus que les débats ont été de
bonne tenue donc on peut pas on peut pas
complètement dire que les oppositions
ont bloquées parce que c'est pas vrai il
y a quand même eu des débats qui ont pu
se mener dans une relative sérénité donc
là l'idée c'est ce qui explique
différents ministres ces derniers jours
sur les sur les plateaux télés c'est que
ils vont garder certains en fait on n'a
pas on n'a pas pu tout écouter on ne
sait pas sur quoi il portait mais
peut-être que cet amendement restera
dans ils vont un petit peu faire leur
marché il y a eu des il y a eu plus d'un
millier d'amendements qui ont été qui
ont été examinés il en restait encore
énormément
et le gouvernement va aller choisir à
droite à gauche ce qu'il a envie de
garder pour donner des gages aux uns et
aux autres pour montrer qu'on les écoute
donc par exemple on avait le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances Bruno Le Maire
qui était qui était si je me trompe pas
je vous coupe un instant parce que Eric
Coquerel présent de la commission des
finances pardon dynam et celle direct
Eric Coquerel s'exprime ce qui nous
parle des habitants qui arrivent dans un
instant à l'Assemblée pour nous annoncer
le 49 encore plus si c'est doublé depuis
des jours j'allais dire d'un mépris de
l'Assemblée nationale puisqu'on a en
réalité le gouvernement a fait en sorte
que on lanterne sur le débat on a
simplement examiné 840 amendements j'ai
jamais vu le gouvernement et une
majorité ne pas chercher accélérer les
débats quand il veut essayer d'atteindre
j'allais dire le vote d'une loi avant la
fin des débats prévus et restait
aujourd'hui les débats les plus
importants sur le CVAE c'est-à-dire les
impôts de production au gouvernement
pouvait être battus sur la taxation sur
les super profits sur les collectivités
et donc il interrompt j'allais dire pour
cesser les morragies des défaites qu'il
a accumulé parce que tout simplement ce
49-3 c'est l'aveu d'échec d'un
gouvernement qui est minoritaire dans
l'assemblée et qui donc passe en force
voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
un jour anodin apparemment on s'attend à
d'autres 49-3 avec le PLFSS ou le PLF
dans sa partie 2 que je crois que pour
notre démocratie notre République c'est
un vrai problème qui est posé
aujourd'hui
voilà la prise de parole d'Éric Coquerel
présent de la commission des finances
alors que Elisabeth borne doit annoncer
d'une minute à l'autre il y a une
suspension de séance de 10 minutes et
tout de suite derrière la première
ministre annoncera l'utilisation du 49-3
pour adopter le budget 2023 c'est ce
qu'il disait c'est la discussion qu'on
avait juste avant Dina il y a des
amendements qui ont été votés les débats
ont continué et maintenant et bien
prise de décision d'Elizabeth borne on
va faire son marché on va prendre
certains il le fait que
pour écouter Fabien Roussel quand même
mais oui il faut l'écouter le le chef
des communistes
nous préparons un coup de force
démocratique un véritable coupé qui va
s'abattre sur tous les débats que nous
avons menés depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant le dernier espoir qui nous
reste c'est que les amendements qui ont
été adoptés majoritairement au sein de
cette émission soit retenu au moins dans
le projet de loi de finances que le
gouvernement s'apprête à conserver en
mettant fin au débat c'est vraiment un
coup dur pour la démocratie et les mêmes
qui nous donnent des leçons sur le
respect des accords majoritaires dans
les entreprises sont les mêmes qui ici
vont s'asseoir sur les votes
majoritaires qui se sont exprimés
pendant ce PLF c'est vraiment un déni de
démocratie un coup de force et c'est
très dur pour l'ensemble des
parlementaires voilà l'espoir de Fabien
Roussel qui espère que certains des
amendements votés depuis le début de la
semaine seront conservés par les
habitants
aussi que là chacun est dans son rôle
c'est vrai vous l'avez vous l'avez
raison de le dire
plus de force on s'attend pas autre
chose de la gauche et des mots très durs
ils vont être employés par toutes les
oppositions que ce soit le RN les
républicains la nuque tout le monde va
expliquer que que c'est un coup de force
que c'est un démocratie que c'est un
mépris de l'Assemblée nationale chacun
est dans son rôle en disant ça
évidemment ils vont pas les lire c'est
formidable
l'Assemblée le gouvernement nous passe
au dessus parce que ça reste c'est ce
qui se passe c'est que on va faire fille
en partie des débats qui ont eu lieu
pour faire passer un texte
après voilà c'est c'est ça a été il y a
aussi le principe de réalité du
gouvernement qui
qui sont 149,3 dans l'état actuel de
l'Assemblée n'allait pas réussir à faire
passer son texte
soit payé au mois de janvier c'est un
texte qui est obligatoire s'il y a pas
de budget s'il y a pas de budget le pays
bascule dans une situation quand même
très particulière et c'est vrai que dans
tous les cas de toute façon le
gouvernement n'allait pas avoir de
majorité pour ce texte donc le
gouvernement n'allait pas réussir à
adopter son texte vous me dites qu'on
est dans des postures finalement
chacun est dans son rôle il y a quand
même une arme que peut utiliser la
gauche la motion de censure la gauche
oui vous avez raison et le rassemblement
national aussi qui envisage de le faire
oui parce que dans le quand le
gouvernement
active le 49-3 il engage aussi la
responsabilité de ce gouvernement et
donc
les oppositions peuvent déposer une
motion de censure
ce qui avait été le cas aussi d'ailleurs
quand Elisabeth band n'avait pas
prononcé le discours de politique
générale devant le gouvernement pour
engager la confiance elle avait prononcé
le discours mais elle n'avait pas engagé
la confiance des députés dans ces cas-là
les députés avaient aussi déposé
l'émotion de censure donc là on va avoir
normalement deux motions qui vont être
déposées une du RN et une de la nups
sachant que la question c'est est-ce que
le RN va les députés RN voteront la
notion de censure de la Nupe et
inversement déjà la motion de censure
c'est quoi une motion de censure qui est
qui est adoptée
la confiance avec le gouvernement et
le gouvernement elle fait tomber le
gouvernement alors renverse le
gouvernement et pour adopter ce texte il
faut une majorité à l'Assemblée donc il
faut 289 députés ce que peuvent avoir
les oppositions si elles sont en toutes
sauf que comme c'est difficile dans la
rue ça allait aussi à l'Assemblée la
conversion la convergence des luttes
c'est pas encore quelque chose qu'on
arrive à faire et le RN a déjà dit qu'a
priori il ne voterait pas en faveur de
l'émotion de censure de la nuque il y a
eu des débats internes du côté des
insoumis notamment sur quelle altitude
adopter face à la motion de temps sur du
RN mais vraisemblablement il devrait pas
voter la leur non plus ce qui fait qu'on
aura deux motions de censure qui une
fois de plus envoient un message c'est à
dire que si une motion de censure
récupère tous les voies du RN et l'autre
toutes les voies de la nuque elle ne
s'additionnent pas et combien même une
de ses motion serait votées par les deux
parties ça ne suffirait encore pas parce
que il n'aurait pas la majorité il
faudrait en plus des votes de députés à
l'air donc on est très loin de pouvoir
faire tomber le gouvernement on est bien
d'accord donc donc mais ça ça va être
quelque chose qui va probablement se
répéter pendant ce gouvernement après on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'une coalition
des oppositions mais il va il va
probablement y avoir plusieurs notions
de censure qui vont à chaque fois ne pas
ne pas arriver à terme après mathildeau
la présidente du groupe insoumi disait
ce matin sur France 2 qu'elle était
consciente que ça que ça ne que ça
n'aboutirait pas mais que sur le
principe ça reste important de montrer
que ceux qui dépose cette notion de
censure ne sont pas contents de de la
manière dont les choses se passent et ça
envoie quand même un message qui a un
certain poids même si c'est un aboutit
pas nous venons d'entendre la la cloche
qui résonne ça veut dire que les députés
sont rappelés à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle on les voit se diriger ici
on est seul des cartes colonnes on peut
expliquer c'est là où les journalistes
attendent ou les députés qui veulent
prendre la parole pas ceux qui ne
veulent pas
et vient permanent donc c'est c'est en
fait le l'endroit où les députés sortent
de l'hémicycle et se font en général
alpaguer par des journalistes qui les
attendent
parfois depuis des heures on a vu
arriver
Eric Coquerel et Fabien Roussel qui sont
venus directement et qui sont repartis
voilà ils sont venus ils savent que
c'est vrai qu'ils peuvent prendre la
parole c'est vraiment la salle où on est
vue où on voit ce qui se passe ou on
veut se montrer et c'est la salle des
échanges avec les journalistes et c'est
une assez petite salle par rapport à par
rapport à ce dont on a l'impression à la
télé et c'est une salle où il fait chaud
il y a pas beaucoup de place
si vous nous rejoignez il est 17h37
moments importants de ce quinquennat le
49-3 va être activé dans un instant par
Elisabeth borne la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
et va faire passer le budget 2023 sans
vote à l'Assemblée nationale et puis au
Sénat évidemment elle doit prendre la
parole d'un instant à l'autre on va
l'écouter Elisabeth borne
c'est un événement
oui et non est-ce que vraiment là
aujourd'hui les Français sont vend
debout se disent le 49-3 des nid
démocratie ou il est rentré voilà dans
les habitudes 49-3 c'est
un premier de ce quinquennat
précédent enfin celui d'Emmanuel Macron
sur la réforme des retraites et puis ça
n'était pas allé au bout oui non c'est
ça exactement donc finalement il y avait
une covid donc ça n'avait pas abouti et
donc finalement le vrai 49-3 remonte si
je dis pas de bêtises à la loi à la loi
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2015 quand il était
ministrement
donc bon assez ironiquement la dernière
personne qui était concernée par 49 3C
Emmanuel Macron
ça avait été un mauvais souvenir pour
lui qu'il avait il faisait tout pour
l'éviter ce 49 ans
pour trouver des soutiens mais ça
n'avait pas suffi et donc c'était sous
la présidence de François Hollande et
François Hollande lui-même d'ailleurs il
y a quelques jours
légitimer le recours au 49 francs en
disant que de toute façon un budget
devait être adopté et que les débats
avaient assez duré et qu'il était donc
temps d'activer d'activer le 49-3 voilà
on pouvait dire en attendant
qu'Elizabeth borne les députés vous le
voyez j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a
plus beaucoup qui traînent dans les
couloirs Wally Bordas notre journaliste
sur place nous dit que la tension monte
que l'hémicycle est plein à craquer ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas donc c'est
un moment important nous verrons quelle
est l'accueil réservée à Isabelle borne
avant même qu'elle prenne la parole
est-ce qu'elle sera sifflée par exemple
alors il y a toujours le respect de la
fonction du Premier ministre de la
première ministre
on rappelle ce qu'est le 49-3 pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent Dina pour expliquer
que là on est face à un moment assez
important de se quinquennat
fait référence à l'article 49 alinéa 3
qui permet au gouvernement de d'engager
sa responsabilité en adoptant un texte
sans passer par le processus législatif
habituel à savoir normalement le vote
des députés puis le vote des sénateur
puis de nouveau le vote de député je
crois voir Elizabeth dans un instant
vous êtes bien pressé je vais la montrer
et les abeilles born elle arrive dans
l'Assemblée nationale je vais vous
montrer l'image d'un instant et oui on
peut rappeler continuer à expliquer donc
pas de vote
c'est ce que les oppositions appellent
un passage en force
puisqu'on fait fille du débat et et
voilà je vois apparaître Elisabeth borne
qui arrive Elisabeth la première
ministre et puis on se retrouve tout à
l'heure pour des prix
dès cet été nous sommes parvenus à nous
mettre d'accord sur des textes pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des Français
il y a quelques jours vous avez voté le
projet de loi relatif au marché du
travail
hier le projet de loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur a été adopté à une très
large majorité au Sénat
en abordant le débat budgétaire nous
connaissions les difficultés face à nous
un budget traduit une ambition et des
engagements
ce sur lesquels le président de la
République et la majorité se sont
présentés devant les Français
nous aurions pu alors renoncer à la
recherche d'un compromis mais nous avons
fait le choix du dialogue
car si nous ne convergons pas sur tout
nous pouvons nous rejoindre quand
l'intérêt général est en cause
dès cet été le ministre de l'économie
est des finances et celui des comptes
publics ont lancé les dialogues de Bercy
j'ai personnellement reçu tous les
présidents des groupes parlementaires
et ces derniers jours encore en
commission et en séance publique le
débat s'est tenu et nous avons examiné
loyalement toutes les propositions
toutes les idées
mais aujourd'hui deux constats
s'imposent
[Applaudissements]
d'abord au moment où nous parlons au
sixième jour de débat bon nombre
d'amendements sont encore à examiner
[Applaudissements]
et tout indique que nous ne tiendrons
pas les délais prévus pour la discussion
de cette première partie du PLF
ensuite ensuite
et surtout les oppositions toute
réaffirmer leur volonté de rejeter le
texte
en responsabilité nous devons donner un
budget à notre pays
[Applaudissements]
les Français attendent de nous de la
cohérence de l'action et des résultats
aussi
aussi sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
[Applaudissements]
le
texte le s'il vous plaît je présente
aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît seul madame la Première
ministre à la parole le texte que je
présente aujourd'hui n'est pas le
décalque du projet qui vous a été
initialement soumis il a été nourri
complété amender corriger même suite au
débat de ces derniers jours en
commission et dans l'hémicycle
une centaine d'amendements a été retenue
y compris des amendements des
oppositions
cette décision c'est le choix de la
responsabilité
car je le redis nous devons donner un
budget à la France un budget cohérent
avec les engagements pris devant les
Français pas de hausse d'impôts pas de
hausse de déficit
mesdames et messieurs les députés
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés ça
n'est pas la fin du débat sur le projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 ce débat
continuera au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée
nationale et à chaque étape nous
garderons intact notre volonté de
dialogue notre devoir d'action et notre
esprit de responsabilité je vous
remercie merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
l'Assemblée nationale prend acte de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément au
dispositions de l'article 49 à Linéa 3
de la Constitution le texte sur lequel
la première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
17h45 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse ou une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de sa discussion la
séance est levée
[Applaudissements]
voilà on l'attendait j'engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement c'est ce
que vient d'annoncer Elisabeth borne la
première ministre a donc et bien activer
le 49 3 on va avoir des réactions dans
un instant parce qu'on a vu les députés
de la France insoumise notamment une
bonne partie des députés de la nups
notamment quitter quitter l'hémicycle
ils sont salle des quatre colonnes là où
attendent les journalistes pour
recueillir les les différentes réactions
nous allons voir dans un instant si nous
pouvons les écouter
Elisabeth borne qui a annoncé que le
texte ne serait pas exactement le même
que celui présenté au début des débats
qu'il serait nourri et bien des
amendements fruits des différents débats
depuis plusieurs jours avec les députés
de la majorité et puis le députés de
l'opposition évidemment sans amendement
seront conservés c'est ce qu'il y a
annoncé la la première la première
ministre et juste après la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a LeBron
Pivet à elle aussi pris la parole et a
rappelé qu'une motion de censure pouvait
être déposée mais il y a un temps
imparti c'est jusqu'à demain demain
17h45 et à ce moment-là donc si cette
notion de censurée est votée il y a peu
de chances que ça arrive mais fait
partie de la Constitution et bien à ce
moment-là il y aura donc la possibilité
pour l'opposition de faire tomber le
gouvernement on écoute ce qu'il se passe
salle des quatre colonnes avec
l'opposition et Boris Vallaud du Parti
socialiste qui prend la parole qui
s'exprime après la prise de parole
d'Élisabeth borne
de la vitalité démocratique nous avons
examiné quatre articles sur 25 nous
avions pour ceux qui nous concerne poser
un nombre très raisonnable d'amendements
et je crois que les débats se sont tenus
dans la sérénité ont été le plus souvent
de qualité nous ne pouvons que regretter
cette méthode la condamner et en appeler
à l'esprit de démocratie de l'exécutif
sur la question de la démocratie le
constat que l'on peut faire c'est que
depuis huit jours
nous ont traités comme des paillassons
c'est-à-dire que nous avons discuté nous
avons discuté nos amendements hier au
soir hier au soir encore avant
l'interruption de séance ils nous ont
dit que le débat les continuer jusqu'au
bout que les amendements seraient
étudiés et aujourd'hui ils font tout le
contraire c'est à dire ils accompagnent
leur brutalité d'un mensonge permanent
et nous ne considérons que c'est une
honte pour notre démocratie de se
comporter de cette façon il y a une
opposition d'une opposition forte c'est
celle qui a été envoyé par les Français
nous demandons ce qu'elles se
respectaient
l'utilisation du 49.3 et un aveu de
faiblesse pour un gouvernement qui ne
sait pas travailler avec la pluralité
politique de l'Assemblée c'est un mépris
pour la qualité des débats nous avons eu
depuis plusieurs jours
[Musique]
qui a été fait depuis des jours par
cette assemblée cela a été dit nous
avons su trouver des majorités sur des
amendements extrêmement importants la
super taxe des taxes sur les super
dividendes la question du crédit d'impôt
sur les EHPAD aujourd'hui ce travail est
balayé balayé en quelques heures pour
finalement répondre un simulacre de
démocratie voilà une semaine que pendant
que nous débattions de manière sereine
et dans un esprit de travail et de
contribution les membres du gouvernement
se succédaient sur les plateaux télé
pour nous dire quand serait utilisé le
49.3 peut-être serait-ce vendredi un an
peut-être bien lundi finalement c'est
mercredi ce simulacre pas l'objectif
faire un écran de fumée médiatique
autour de la contenu du contenu de ce
budget ce budget c'est
l'irresponsabilité climatique c'est
l'incapacité de faire les
investissements pour la transition c'est
la capacité de faire des choix
politiques qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de limiter le dérèglement
climatique mais c'est aussi un budget
pour les plus riches c'est le refus de
reprendre l'impôt de solidité de
solidarité sur la fortune c'est le refus
de la taille sur les supers profits
finalement ce qu'ils font c'est de
refuser le choix des Français et c'est
de contribuer finalement à assécher le
débat démocratique c'est inacceptable
merci
[Musique]
la nupes Unis on a vu Mathilde panot on
l'a raté mais elle a pris la parole
alors que la présence de l'Assemblée
nationale était encore en train de
parler on a écouté Boris Vallaud du
Parti socialiste on a écouté André
Chassaigne pour les communistes et là
c'est Cyril Chalain que vous venez
d'entendre qui est la présidente du
groupe Europe Écologie Les Verts à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui évidemment
utilise des mots attendus déni
démocratie une motion de censure sera
sûrement déposée dans les heures qui
viennent puisque la nups a jusqu'à
demain 17h45 pour pour déposer cette
motion de censure après l'annonce il y a
quelques instants d'Élisabeth borne
d'utiliser le 49-3 le fameux article
49-3 qui permet au gouvernement
d'engager sa responsabilité mais surtout
de faire passer ce texte sans le vote
des députés nous restons à l'Assemblée
nationale nous écoutons ce qu'il se
passe ici salle des quatre colonnes
c'est juste à la sortie de l'hémicycle
là où les députés viennent prendre la
parole on attend peut-être des députés
de la majorité qui viendront défendre ce
que vient de dire Elisabeth borne ce que
vient d'annoncer Elisabeth borne avec ce
49-3 puis peut-être des élus également
du rassemblement national qui a aussi
l'intention de poser de déposer une
motion de censure peut-être des députés
des républicains on reste ensemble on
reste sur ces images à l'Assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
l'usage
de 49,3 par le gouvernement n'est pas
une surprise on sait depuis le 19 juin
que le gouvernement ne dispose pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
et donc qu'il est contraint l'emploi du
49-3 il avait d'autant moins de chance
de trouver une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale que ce budget pour nous
aggrave dangereusement la situation de
la France avec un déficit de 155
milliards une dette de 3000 milliards et
je viens de rappeler au terme de ce
quinquennat à ce rythme là ça veut dire
que les intérêts payés par la France
s'élèveront à 100 milliards par an c'est
à dire plus que le budget du ministère
d'éducation nationale et du ministère de
l'Intérieur réuni donc ce budget il est
irresponsable il est dangereux pour la
situation financière de notre pays et en
aucun cas nous pouvions le voter le
gouvernement en a d'autres n'ont pas
d'autres choix que celui de ce 49 une
arme que lui propose la Constitution
maintenant si le gouvernement n'a pas de
majorité c'est pas le fruit du hasard
c'est pas le fruit d'une erreur des
Français qui aurait mal voté mais une
volonté des Français d'obliger la
majorité de vigiles le gouvernement à
écouter l'ensemble des formations
politiques qui les représentent et donc
évidemment
nous demandons au gouvernement c'est le
premier 49-3 mais il y en aura d'autres
durant le temps que durera ce
quinquennat il y en aura sans doute 5 6
d'ici la fin de d'ici la fin de de la
session d'ici Noël et donc mon nom
gouvernement évidemment de retenir un
maximum des propositions qui ont été
faites par les différents groupes
d'opposition
est-ce que vous comptez éventuellement
signer une motion de censure parce qu'il
va y avoir aussi une censure
Olivier Marleix le président du groupe
LR à l'Assemblée nationale qui parle
d'un budget responsable qui n'est pas
étonné que le gouvernement et la
majorité face
usage du 49-3 il demande quand même à la
première ministre de retenir un maximum
d'amendements tous ces amendements qui
ont été débattus votés par les
oppositions avec la majorité évidemment
depuis le début de la semaine sur ce sur
ce budget mais vous l'avez entendu il ne
votera pas de motion de censure il reste
plus mesuré il dit qu'il ne serait pas
sérieux de rajouter du désordre alors
que l'Assemblée nationale c'est vrai
commence à peine à trouver ces marques
puisqu'il y a eu une session
extraordinaire juste après législatives
une pause pendant les vacances et puis
les débats ont repris il y a quelques
semaines à peine quelques jours à peine
donc non les députés LR ne voteront pas
de motion de censure si la nupesse si le
rassemblement national venait à en
déposer une voilà pour la prise de
parole d'Olivier Marleix le président du
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale il est
17h57 je vous rappelle qu'Elisabeth
borne il y a quelques minutes à a pris
la parole pour annoncer que le
gouvernement mettait en gage sa
responsabilité et faisait usage du 49-3
pour faire adopter le budget 2023 nous
sommes ici salle des quatre colonnes ou
les députés passent lorsqu'ils sortent
de l'hémicycle nous attendons encore les
réactions peut-être de la majorité
évidemment du rassemblement national
nous avons attendu entendu il y a
quelques instants les députés de la de
la nupes qui eux évidemment par d'un
déni de démocratie nous verrons si le
rassemblement national utilise les mêmes
termes et confirme que une motion de
censure aura déposée par le groupe de
Marine Le Pen on reste ensemble à
l'Assemblée nationale
et
c'est le plus déposer de
mousse à l'annonce du 49 novembre
[Musique]
ensemble des groupes de la nups sont
signataires de ces émotions de censure
151 députés c'est ça absolument
pardon
on l'a déposé dès l'annonce par la
ministre du 49-3 donc il y a quelques
minutes et ce sera enregistré alors là
c'est pour le moment on n'a pas la date
bien sûr la Conférence des Présidents va
se réunir après on sait que là il y
avait 24 heures pour réagir après la
longé 49-3 qu'on a 48 heures ensuite de
délai
c'est ça donc ça sera vendredi soir
samedi ou lundi on attend de voir un peu
mais en tout cas vous annoncez que le
texte nous l'avions dit elle a annoncé
le 49 fois nous l'avons fait nous avons
déposé notre notion de censure
c'est des premiers signataires bien
évidemment
le contenu du texte mais finalement
c'est les trois filets qu'on nous a
présenté tout à l'heure la première
c'est un gouvernement sans majorité sans
finalement qui n'a pas demandé la
confiance qui a été mis en difficulté
sur la trajectoire budgétaire financière
c'est un gouvernement qui ne sait pas
faire avec la pluralité de l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'une teint pas compte des
résultats des élections législatives
donc on est un gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui en situation de fébrilité et
de fragilité la deuxième chose c'est
l'irresponsabilité climatique je l'ai
dit il faut regarder au-delà de la forme
le contenu de ce budget pourquoi est-ce
que nous sommes opposés à un certain
nombre de ces mesures pourquoi nous
avons cherché à proposer à l'amender
avec l'ISF climatique c'est un budget
qui ne prend pas en concurrence
climatique aujourd'hui c'est
inacceptable si nous voulons être sur
une trajectoire pour nous protéger
protéger nos enfants les actions c'est
aujourd'hui et la deuxième chose c'est
un
j'ai complètement déconnecté de la
réalité face à l'inflation aujourd'hui
quand les Français travaillent chaque
euro qu'il gagne vaut beaucoup moins on
le voit ça veut dire se restreindre sur
l'alimentation ce restreinte sur les
dépenses de carburant ou de chauffage ou
sur restreinte sur les loisirs aucun
compte n'est tenu de cette situation de
crise sociale on continue de faire des
cadeaux fiscaux aux grandes entreprises
on refuse d'ouvrir la question du
partage des richesses aujourd'hui on
pourrait faire un autre budget qui
répond à ces deux enjeux de l'urgence
climatique et de l'urgence sociale ce
n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui on a fait un on a fait une
motion de censure qui rappelle ces trois
principes et qui redit notre projet de
société
nous l'avons rédigé de manière à être
clair sur notre projet de société la
question de l'égalité la question de la
justice sociale la question de la
responsabilité climatique et aujourd'hui
clairement je pense qu'on a aucun
rapport entre le projet de société du RN
excluant et le projet que nous nous
proposons pour protéger les Français
mais elle sera votée par les membres de
la vitesse et aujourd'hui je pense que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir un
vote vous rendez compte qu'après le
dépôt du 49.3 ça veut dire le refus du
vote sur le budget de l'État le refus du
vote de l'Assemblée nationale sur nos
priorités politiques et donc déjà sans
mention de censure pas de vote
en fait ce n'est pas rien nous avons une
assemblée
on a une assemblée qui s'est réuni qui a
travaillé qui a adoptait des amendements
on a un travail qui est balayé et
méprisé il est normal dans une
démocratie que les parlementaires
déposent une motion de censure pour
demander un vote on verra les résultats
de sur votre nous disons cette notion de
censure elle est clairement sur nos
fondamentaux et rappeler en fait le
gouvernement finalement n'a fait qu'un
débat de forme nous voulons ramener le
débat sur le fond quel est le contenu de
ce budget aujourd'hui ce budget est un
mauvais budget pour la France et c'est
ça qu'elle dit cette notion de sensuelle
dit regardez les cadeaux qui sont faits
au plus riches regardez finalement le
dogmatisme avec lequel le gouvernement
refuse de remettre l'impôt de solidarité
sur la feutriture regardez le refus de
prendre en compte l'urgence climatique
ceci faut le remettre dans le débat
après le feuilleton qui a été posé
pendant des jours sur le calendrier du
49-3 au mépris de l'Assemblée mais
finalement même au mépris des Français
de poser les vrais débats dans la
discussion publique parce que la vérité
n'assume pas ce budget pour les plus
riches et qui est complètement
irresponsable
nous sommes pas des marchands de tapis
l'Assemblée nationale vote elle a voté
des amendements l'ensemble le respect de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est de reprendre
l'ensemble de zemlins nous ne sommes pas
là pour discuter de ce qui doit être
pris ou non nous sommes là pour
permettre le respect des majorités qui
se sont construites
merci beaucoup
vous venez d'entendre Cyrielle châtelain
c'est la présidente du groupe Europe
Écologie Les Verts à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc elle est revenue
devant les journalistes pour annoncer
qu'une motion de censure avait été
déposée par par la nupes les quatre
parties donc les Verts les communistes
la France insoumise et les socialistes
salit donc pour et bien déposer cette
notion de censure on entendait un petit
malaise quand même lors des questions
des journalistes pour savoir si ils
attendaient un vote de la part de la
part du rassemblement national
visiblement non et il ne voteront pas
une notion de censure déposée par le
rassemblement national on écoute ce qui
se passe à l'Assemblée
oui Mathieu Lefebvre je suis débuté du
Val-de-Marne
49,3 et de la responsabilité des
oppositions qui toutes les unes après
les autres et avant même d'avoir lu la
première ligne du budget nous ont dit on
va voter contre nous on est un
gouvernement et une majorité responsable
et on sait que la France elle a besoin
d'un budget elle a besoin de payer ses
fonctionnaires elle a besoin de protéger
les Français les entreprises les
collectivités de l'inflation au 1er
janvier prochain pour ça le 49-3 c'est
l'arme qui est utilisée par le
gouvernement mais c'est une arme de
responsabilité
on est dans un état social comme
aujourd'hui les comment dire pertinents
de parler d'armes est-ce que on n'aurait
pas pu continuer alors que les débats se
passaient relativement bien l'Assemblée
nationale prendre un peu plus de temps
pour justement respecter les oppositions
sachant qu'on n'avez pas la majorité
absolue 49-3 c'est un outil qui a été
utilisé avant le gouvernement
d'Elizabeth borne et je vais vous faire
une confidente il sera utilisé après le
gouvernement des Elisabeth borne et
j'observe simplement que la
responsabilité elle n'inconde pas cette
majorité elle incombe à tous les toutes
les oppositions qui nous ont dit prenez
cet amendement prenez cet amendement
mais qui dans l'ensemble nous ont toutes
dit nos refusons nous formons une
minorité de blocage pour faire en sorte
que la France n'est pas de budget moi je
suis désolé je veux que la France elle
puisse avoir un budget sur les débats on
a eu une semaine de débat près de 10
jours de débats il y a près de 1000
amendements qui ont été examinés
personne ne peut dire ici que on n'a pas
laissé le temps au départ
sur les bateaux mais on peut écouter de
la nuket c'est ce que vous répondez à ça
moi je réponds qu'il y a eu 10 jours de
débat 1000 amendements examinés je sais
pas s'ils appellent ça un débatform mais
la posture de forme que l'on peut
critiquer c'est celle qui consiste à
dire avant même toute chose avant même
d'avoir examiné le premier amendement on
va voter contre votre budget pourquoi
parce que c'est le budget de la macronie
comme ils disent et dans le fond les
oppositions aujourd'hui elles
constituent des majorités de
circonstances et nous à l'inverse on a
une majorité politique c'est bien ça qui
nous différencie
c'est un échec pour toutes les
oppositions qui pensaient être les
agents du compromis le compromis suppose
des agents du compromis et encore une
fois si demain il y a des oppositions
qui viennent nous dire on a telle et tel
projet et on est capable de vous suivre
là-dessus si c'est cohérent avec notre
projet politique qui consiste à moins
taxer les Français et à ne pas nous
endetter alors on prendra tous ces
propositions
on veut des oppositions qui soient
constructives pas des oppositions qui
s'opposent pour s'opposer et qui salit
les unes aux autres pour je le répète
faire battre la macronie au mépris de
leur propre cohérence et au mépris de
leur cohérence idéologique
merci
c'était Mathieu Lefebvre député
Renaissance membre de la commission des
finances qui est le premier
député de la majorité qui est venu
défendre donc l'annonce d'Élisabeth
borne tout à l'heure le 49.3 est activé
pour faire passer le budget 2023 et oui
il n'y avait pas de majorité absolue il
n'y a pas de majoritaire absolue dans
cette Assemblée nationale il fallait
donc
pour le gouvernement et bien activer ce
49-3 il n'y avait pas d'autres solutions
puisque ce vote du budget est un
marqueur vous votez pour vous êtes dans
la majorité vous votez contre vous êtes
dans l'opposition il était donc
extrêmement difficile voire impossible
d'aller chercher des voix ailleurs dans
les autres groupes pour faire passer ce
budget une motion de censure a donc été
déposée par la nupes nous venons
d'entendre tirer le châtelain il y a
quelques minutes qui après la parole
tient le RN nous les avons pas entendu
Jean-Philippe Tanguy prend la parole
maintenant c'est vous qui avez commencé
alors
je sais pas si c'est possible merci
votre votre réaction par rapport
aux était assez inévitable du
gouvernement en raison de votre solution
oui à ce qui est surtout inévitable
c'est la médiocrité constante de Madame
borne qui a fait un discours une fois de
plus d'une intelligence d'une indigence
républicaine assez rare qui n'a parlé
pour ne rien dire et donc il constate
que ce qu'elle aurait pu faire au début
elle le fait après 6 jours de débat en
considérant qu'il y a des bons et des
mauvais amendements alors qu'il n'y a
que les amendements qui ont été adoptés
par les représentants du peuple français
y compris d'ailleurs ceux que nous-mêmes
nous n'avons pas soutenus donc c'est un
comportement vraiment à la fois
inexplicable et qui prouve à mon avis
que ce gouvernement est perdu en fait de
ne s'est pas vraiment ce qu'il fait et
n'est donc incapable de répondre aux
problèmes des Français
[Musique]
non nous allons la déposer demain Marine
Le Pen et le groupe veut prendre le
temps de choisir les bons modes pas
avoir de réaction pavlovienne de faire
un texte qui correspond à la situation
est-ce qu'on a attendu jusqu'à présent
parce que avant la motion de censure on
a eu un vote par exemple sur la
contribution de la France à l'Union
européenne je rappelle que c'est 24
milliards d'euros le RN est le seul
groupe va essayer de reposer en total
cohérence donc on va adapter cela et on
veut aussi faire une motion qui n'est
pas du pur qui n'est pas purement la
position du RN qui est une analyse de la
situation objective pour que peut-être
d'autres forces politiques la
soutiennent est-ce que éventuellement
vous allez voter la notion que vient de
déposer la nuit face je ne sais pas j'ai
pas vu le texte donc moi je n'ai pas
contrairement à eux j'ai pas de réaction
Pavlo Fiat le vote selon l'intérêt de la
France donc c'est
possible de New ORL en disant vous ne
votez pas le texte de la nuit il y a pas
encore de consigne qui ont été données
ce qui a dit Marine Le Pen c'est que
compte tenu des positions de laupestre
pendant ces quelques jours notamment sur
le financement de la politique
migratoire sur le mépris pour le soutien
à nos forces de l'ordre ça me paraît
compliqué de voter une notion de la
nupestre puisque je crains qu'ils en
face mention dans leur texte par
ailleurs il au Parlement européen demain
de questions qu'est-ce que vous pensez
justement de la manière dont enfin
est-ce que vous ne craignez pas les
sanctions finissent par aggraver la
situation pour les Français j'ai pas
entendu ce qu'espérer comme des bas au
Parlement européens
vous criez que le renchérissement du
bout de l'énergie qui est aussi dû au
sanction contre la Russie est-ce que
vous criez qu'un
monde c'est pas qu'on le craint c'est
qu'on l'a annoncé dénoncé et qu'on a
prévenu les Français que la partie de
ces sanctions contre la Russie il y a
des parties qui sont utiles et qui ne
pénalisent pas les Français les
sanctions contre les oligarques contre
le système financier et il y a le si il
y a les sanctions qui pénalisent les
Européens parce qu'en fait nous sommes
tellement dépendants de la Russie pour
nos importations de matières premières à
cause de la politique européenne puisque
c'est l'Union européenne qui a soutenu
par exemple le développement des
oléoducs et des gazoducs verts la Russie
et pas le rassemblement national que les
décisions qui sont prises enrichissent
le régime russe et appauvrissent les
Européens
sur la motion de censure à quoi ça sert
de déposer le son de censure si vous ne
votez pas celle de la vitesse mais déjà
ça sert à affirmer une position
politique une analyse politique une
critique du gouvernement a le Parlement
vous défendez des options parce que vous
y croyez que vous affirmez ce pourquoi
les Français vous ont élu après je ne
sais pas ce que vous faire aussi les
autres forces politiques qu'est-ce qu'au
final va faire LR qu'est-ce que au final
va vous faire les élus de l'iode je n'en
sais rien elle est a priori il ne
dépense pas de me
suivre sur Palerme décidé de voter ni la
vôtre initiale de la nuit passée oui
c'est un bon résumé de la position de LR
depuis quelques mois voire quelques
années c'est qu'on sait pas où ils sont
où ils vont et qu'ils sont
pour travailler on faisait de
l'enseignant c'est quand vous dit comme
ça dans toutes les 25 quel est votre
santé non mais moi j'ai pas de ressenti
personnel moi qui a ressenti par rapport
aux Français qui ont des Francs on a
voté des amendements importants pour eux
sont des dépenses utiles par exemple
l'augmentation du crédit pour l'accueil
des enfants la demi-part fiscale pour
toutes les veuves et les femmes de
guerre quel que soit leur âge on a aussi
voté des amendements utiles pour
rétablir l'équilibre des finances
publiques je pense à l'amendement qui
vient du modem sur les survivants des
sur les surafats d'action qui sont deux
méthodes que j'avais proposé moi au nom
du RN à l'issue de la mission flash ou
le rétablissement de nexit tax donc ce
qui est très étrange avec ces
gouvernement c'est qu'il a accusé le les
oppositions d'être incapable de trouver
des recettes et de vouloir faire des
dépenses et qu'ils vont retenir
finalement quelques dépenses et refuser
toutes les recettes
merci beaucoup merci
si vous êtes
la question
va sans doute déposer une motion
vous dit avec le
rfmment clair depuis toujours nous ne
frayons pas avec l'extrême droite le
frayons pas avec le rassemblement
national et nous nous voterons jamais
une motion du ration de Front National
et voilà notre on joue même pour vous
avec eux vous voyez que on est quand
même
clairement constant en la matière mais
moi ce que je voudrais dire surtout
c'est que nous avons examiné quatre
articles sur 26 pas considérer que nous
ayons examiné sérieusement ce budget
nous regardons la liste des concessions
faites par un gouvernement qui a
recherché compromis quelle blague il
manque l'essentiel des amendements
importants que la représentation
nationale avait voté je pense à la taxe
sur les super dividendes qui venaient
des bancs de la majorité de Monsieur
Mattei je pense écrire un mot la
transformation en crédit d'impôts de
l'aide qui était accordée aux résidents
en EHPAD donc on sait le reste à charge
pour les résidents et pour les familles
qui ont des proches qui sont dans les
EHPAD c'était un scandale il n'y a rien
qui soit véritablement sérieux sur la
taxation des super profits rien sur
l'exita rien sur
l'isfait franchement c'est on s'y
attendait on va vous mentir et je crois
que vous aussi vous seriez pas là mais
c'est quand même très décevant sur le
plan du débat démocratique nous sommes
un parlement plus réaliste plus réaliste
que jamais avec un parlementarisme de
fait issus des urnes souhaité par les
Français
qui exigent de nouvelles pratiques de la
part en particulier de l'exécutif ce
budget il était il aurait été celui de
l'Assemblée nationale et bien c'est le
budget de l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui le gouvernement refuse de
voter
à une farce on a 26 articles on a des
sujets très importants
que par écho
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour en plateau au
Figaro nous venons d'entendre les
différentes réactions à l'Assemblée
nationale avec le député du
rassemblement national Jean-Philippe
dingue avec Boris Vallaud le député du
Parti socialiste bonjour Guillaume
Rocket bonjour Merci d'être ici bon on
va analyser ce qui vient de se passer
pas vraiment une surprise Elisabeth
borne annonce le 49-3 de toute façon
c'était inévitable pourquoi on a attendu
autant de temps parce que il fallait que
le gouvernement montre sa bonne volonté
il y a eu lors des dernières
législatives une sorte de message
subliminal envoyé par les Français en
disant ok Emmanuel Macron a été réalisé
de la République on va lui donner un
certain nombre de députés mais on veut
pas qu'il ait tous les pouvoirs donc on
veut qu'il parle avec les autres et
qu'il essaie de faire émerger un
consensus bon c'est le travail
d'Élisabeth borde évidemment ça n'a pas
marché mais il y a quand même eu 55
heures d'échange il y a des amendements
de l'opposition ou des oppositions qui
va être retenues donc un le gouvernement
a montré sa bonne volonté de il veut
sortir du blocage et donc motion de
censure je trouve que une séquence
médiatiquement est assez bien gérée et
donc 49-3 et donc vous l'avez dit motion
de censure on peut expliquer pour
l'instant on a entendu il y a quelques
instants c'est la Présidente c'est le
Chatelain du du des écolos à l'Assemblée
nationale qui est venu annoncer et bien
qu'une motion de censure était déposée
le RN pour l'instant dit nous on n'a pas
de réflexe Pablo vient on va discuter
oui mais d'après ce que j'entends ils
sont sur le point dans déposer une voilà
donc il va y avoir effectivement deux
motions de censure on rappelle le les
caractéristiques techniques de ce 49-3
c'est l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution qui donc permet à un
gouvernement de faire passer un texte
sans vote en disant je vous propose
d'adopter ce vote
ce texte de loi pardon en l'occurrence
le projet de loi de finances et ensuite
le texte est réputé comme étant adopté
sauf si une motion de censure emporte la
majorité
[Musique]
sur ce
budgeter une motion de censure je crois
pas parce qu'on a entendu pour tout vous
dire Guillaume Olivier Marie c'est un
instant qui lui a dit non non
certainement pas en déposera pas de
motion de censure on n'est pas content
parce que le budget n'a ni que ni tête
mais on veut pas de rajouter du de chaos
à la situation voilà ce que dit Olivier
Marley c'est ce qu'il tire bien ses
troupes c'est vrai
a priori il ne devrait pas y avoir de
motion de censure de la même façon que
il y a déjà des textes législatifs
notamment le le projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui sont passés depuis
cette nouvelle législature et malgré
l'absence de majorité absolue pour le
les troupes d'Emmanuel Macron parce que
il y avait une bonne volonté évidente
des députés LR si vous voulez ce ce
nouveau ce budget 2023 c'est Noël au
mois d'octobre je voulais il y a de
l'argent pour tout le monde sauf pour ce
malheur
oui mais mais ça plaît pas où aller sur
le principe mais sur le fond si vous
voulez les députés dans la
circonscription on leur dit on voudrait
un peu d'argent pour tel projet pour
telle activité pour telle aide et comme
le gouvernement est généreux c'est
difficile d'aller contre ça
qui est pas forcément très généreux
c'est lui alors il a dit hein ce sera
sans moi si on fait n'importe quoi et
qu'on accepte tout c'est vrai alors d'un
point de vue technique tous les
ministères voilà leur budget augmenter
l'année prochaine sauf deux le ministère
des Anciens Combattants et le ministère
de l'Économie ce malheureux Bruno Le
Maire essaye de de de convaincre ces
petits camarades que on peut pas
dépenser de l'argent indéfiniment en
pure perte la preuve c'est que tous les
autres budgets augmentent mais lui il
est dans une logique politique lui il
veut apparaître comme étant le côté
raisonnable du macronisme c'est comme
évidemment dans l'Union européenne on
dit les frugaux et les ceux qui
dépensent les autres et on les appelle
je sais plus exactement les pays du Club
Med qui étaient les pays du sud de
l'Europe sauf que
c'est surtout les les discours de Bruno
Le Maire qui sont frugaux parce que pour
le reste quand vous voyez le niveau
d'endettement auquel on va arriver
l'année prochaine et le niveau de
déficit budgétaire veut pas dire quand
même bon alors vous me dites que
personne n'est content la nuit pêche le
rassemblement national parce qu'on ne
donne pas assez
les la droite parce qu'on dépense trop
et dans tout ça la majorité fait son
miel tout va bien elle fait passer ce
texte alors elle va l'utiliser encore un
certain nombre de fois car 9 3 c'est pas
un c'est pas un coup un coup d'une fois
là parce que ce budget il faut le voter
les dépenses les recettes c'est
compliqué voilà alors d'abord
effectivement
vous avez raison il y a des oppositions
des deux côtés pour des raisons
différentes et Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement applique le en même temps
c'est assez logique et il faut
reconnaître que c'est relativement
efficace à condition de ne rien faire
c'est-à-dire que le prix à payer si vous
voulez de cette espèce de de centrisme
ou de juste milieu c'est une absence de
décision forte il y a vous êtes
incapable j'en suis persuadé et pourtant
vous avez bossé de de me citer une
mesure très forte de ce budget qui va
être absolument bouleversante pour les
Français vous avez raison celle qu'on
retient finalement ce sont les
amendements que l'on était votés en
cours de route exactement qui ont été
votés ou qui ont été rejetés et pour le
reste
on en est là dessus vous m'interrogez
sur le 49-3 le principe c'est que cette
ce avant pouvait utiliser indéfiniment
cette technique du 49-3 pour faire
passer autant de textes de loi qu'on
voulait certains ont fait regarde il y a
très longtemps comme a été premier
ministre qu'il avait pas de majorité
claire il a beaucoup utilisé aujourd'hui
c'est plus possible vous pouvez le faire
une fois par session sur un texte de loi
classique une fois pour le projet de
budget et une fois pour le projet du
budget de la Sécurité sociale qu'on
appelle le PLFSS mais plan
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale mais pas simple voilà
c'est c'est pas simple mais
c'est euh cette procédure est valable
pour un texte et pas pour un passage ça
veut dire que vous savez que en France
il y a deux chambres donc l'Assemblée
nationale adopte un texte ensuite
celui-ci par au Sénat parfois d'ailleurs
c'est le Sénat qui le vote en premier il
y a ce qu'on appelle des navettes et
comme c'est globalement toujours le même
texte c'est toujours le budget de la
France pour 2023 et bien il peut y avoir
autant de 49,3 que de passage du texte
devant l'Assemblée nationale il n'est
pas vraiment utilisé au Sénat c'est ça
il est utilisé à l'Assemblée le texte la
va aller au Sénat alors oui le texte que
les textes doivent être il y a le
principe de la navette mais dans le le
bicamérisme à la française il y a deux
chambres mais c'est toujours la somme
nationale qui gagne à la fin c'est un
peu comme la France et l'Allemagne au
foot dans les années 80 et donc le le
même si le Sénat n'adopte pas le texte
ou s'il adopte un texte complètement
transformé par beaucoup le gouvernement
peut dire non non moi c'était pas ça le
budget que je voulais le budget que je
voulais c'était mon texte d'origine et
donc c'est sur celui-là je viendra
l'Assemblée nationale 49-3 à nouveau
exactement voilà parce que le principe
c'est que il y a donc c'est c'est
navettes ensuite il y a une alors
est-ce que la commission mixte paritaire
s'applique au projet de loi de finance
là j'avoue que je donne ma langue au
chat mais c'est aussi apparemment ça
pourrait arriver mais si le gouvernement
n'a pas envie de faire accélérer les
choses il pourrait y avoir faire
l'impasse sur cette commission
mixparitaire qui est une sorte de grande
négociation exactement où chacun peut
donner son avis mais de toute façon
c'est juste une question de temps mais
c'est le gouvernement qui gagne à la fin
sauf si les renversé par une motion de
censure regardez les députés nups et RN
dépose chacun une notion de censure
contre le gouvernement
on vous expliquait qu'il était peu
probable qu'elles aboutissent ces
émotions de censure pour renverser le
gouvernement
c'est un événement ou pas ce 49-3 deux
questions déjà est-ce que c'est un
événement parce que de toute façon on le
savait il allait arriver à 49 il y avait
pas d'autres possibilités
je crois que c'est pas un événement
pour d'autres
d'abord parce que en lui-même c'est une
procédure
constitutionnelle parfaitement classique
puisque encore une fois les les les
rédacteurs de la Constitution de 1958
celle qui organise la Cinquième
République avait prévu ce cas de figure
c'est-à-dire une majorité fragile pour
le gouvernement et donc lui a donné
cette instrument donc si vous voulez ça
n'est pas un coup de force ou et encore
moins un coup d'état ou je ne sais quel
mesure d'exception non c'est fait partie
des des techniques parlementaires un
passage en force d'une certaine manière
un coup d'état c'est beaucoup trop
évidemment mais c'est quand même une
manière de dire écoutez nous les
oppositions vous êtes pas capable de
nous aider on n'est pas constructif et
ben nous on passe en vous quoi quand
même oui vous avez raison mais vous
pouvez aussi retourner l'argument en
disant mais toute façon les oppositions
vous n'êtes pas d'accord entre vous pour
me renverser donc je suis toujours
majoritaire puisque je mettez pas de
majorité contre moi et effectivement
toute majoritaire relative c'est une
majorité relative mais on peut pas dire
que ce soit antidémocratique puisqu'il
n'y a pas une majorité de parlementaire
donc une majorité de représentants de la
nation qui sont contre ce texte enfin
ils sont contre mais ils n'arrivent pas
à s'entendre entre eux pour contrer le
texte à travers une notion de censure
Emmanuel Macron
est-il fervent défenseur du 49-3 j'ai lu
dans les pages du Figaro qui l'aimait
pas vraiment ça est-ce qu'il va tout
faire pour l'éviter alors pour le budget
il aura pas trop le choix on a bien
compris les oppositions ne voteront
certainement pas le budget parce que il
serait comptable du bilan du
gouvernement dans les mois qui viennent
mais pour la réforme des retraites par
exemple voilà c'est toute la question
parce qu'effectivement c'est ça le
rendez-vous important
un autre 49-3 pour la réforme des
retraites au mois de janvier il sera
majeur absolument et des alors à un
moment on avait dit qu'il aurait pu
avoir une réforme des retraites à
travers le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale et qui aurait pu
il pourrait y avoir un 49-3 là pour le
coup vous pouvez avoir une une sorte
d'union sacrée des oppositions alors
est-ce que les LR voteraient ça n'est
pas sûr contre le gouvernement sur ce
projet en revanche le le rassemblement
national et la nuque sont tous les deux
opposés et quasiment dans les mêmes
termes à un report de de l'âge de la
retraite même si la ration nationale dit
que c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
que ça donc là pour le coup
il pourrait y avoir coalition des
oppositions d'autant que les Français
sont majoritairement contre cette
réforme on leur dit est-ce qu'il faut
repousser l'âge de la retraite ils
disent bah ouais ce serait bien alors
est-ce qu'on le fait bien non parce que
forcément ils ont pas envie ils
préfèrent laisser ça leurs enfants et
donc je pense que
toute façon la réforme des retraites si
elle doit passer ou bien le gouvernement
arrive à un accord avec les
parlementaires LR en disant c'est
l'avenir de nos finances publiques qui
est en jeu et donc il arrive à trouver
une majorité ou bien ce qui est voilà ce
qui est ou bien ou bien il devra passer
en force avec un 49-3 qui peut être en
tout cas pas en catimini c'est à dire
que le gouvernement a semble-t-il
abandonné l'idée d'une réforme en douce
entre guillemets des retraites à travers
un texte qui ne soit pas majoritairement
consacré à ce sujet et il a raison
d'avoir abandonné ça parce que c'est
tellement ça va ça va être difficile de
faire accepter cette réforme aux
Français les il y avait pas grand monde
dans les rues ni hier pour la journée de
mobilisation générale ni dimanche pour
le petit tour de Paris à pied de la de
la nuque mais s'il y a une réforme une
vraie réforme des retraites en
particulier si on touche au régime
spéciaux alors là il y aura du monde
donc on ne peut pas avoir une réforme
qui passe en catimini entre guillemets
ce 49-3 utilisé pour le budget
finalement vous me dites les Français
c'est très loin d'eux et on leur dit
presque et si on veut pas ce budget les
fonctionnaires seront pas payés la
France sera à l'arrêt en revanche la
réforme des traites c'est quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus concret est-ce que
le 49-3 c'est banalisé vraiment aux yeux
des Français ou c'est juste parce que là
sur le budget bon c'est moins important
je pense que ce qui s'est banalisé ce
n'est pas le la technique de cette de ce
de ce vote ou de ce non vote des lois je
me trompe j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
quelques années les Français étaient
moins d'accord avec ce 49-3 notamment
sur ce de Manuel Valls par exemple je
pense que c'est moins la technique du
49-3 que le sujet qui est qui est plus
ou moins clivant plus ou moins
de nature à diviser les Français et que
le 49-3 ça n'est qu'un instrument c'est
le contenu des textes qui qui peut
provoquer de graves remous dans le pays
merci beaucoup Guillaume Rocket merci
d'être passé quelques instants je vous
rappelle donc Elisabeth borne a
déclenché l'article 49-3 vous avez sur
Le Figaro.fr vous avez toutes les
dernières informations nous verrons dans
les heures qui viennent maintenant il y
a 48 heures maintenant que les deux
motions de censure de la France
insoumise la nuit PES et du RN sont
déposés 48 heures pour les pour les
voter nous verrons ce qu'il se passe
même si il y a peu de chance on l'a dit
que ces motion de censure soit votées
merci de nous avoir suivi excellente
soirée sur le figure en live